tell us about meeting Malcolm X because
he were in the Oxford Union and he can't
speak dared into look with Malcolm you
know our knowledge my knowledge
certainly but that of that whole
generation which didn't live in the
States about the black struggles in the
United States was very limited and
meeting Malcolm X leaving aside the
speech he made you know I had a chance
to spend two hours with him and he just
explained what that Society was and by
the end of it one was quite
shell-shocked and what really shocked me
at that meeting was when you know you
get up to say goodbye and I said by
Malcolm good to see you great to see you
and I hope we meet again and the guy
you're saying this to says I don't think
we will so you suddenly say but wise
I said why he said I think they're going
to kill me fairly soon so you know I sat
down again I said Malcolm who is going
to kill you
he said the FBI the Nation of Islam a
combination of both and to thought
simultaneously went through my head
either this guys are a bit of a hustler
or he's a very great man simultaneously
and then that night I couldn't sleep I
was thinking but no one had said that to
me you know I was in my early twenties
that this is going and then this was in
November I think and in early February
we opened the front lifted the Guardian
and on the front page Malcolm X
assassinated the whole group of us who I
drilled about that or we just went and
spent that day in in a pub drinking and
crying that this had actually happened
to someone I've met interesting because
his conversion to Islam or the Nation of
Islam firstly and then later sort of
more mainstream Islam now for him
religion was a way of activating
radicalism but for you it never really
never really has been no and it's funny
when he first came up to me
max at the meeting oh you know before
the meeting and we were introduced and
he said our authority Muslim brother I
said hang on Malcolm I said I'm not a
religious person and I'm not a believer
he started laughing he said actually
I've just come from a tour of the Muslim
world and I've met people like you in
Africa and in the arab peninsula and all
this your age your generation saying the
same thing I said well I'll tell you why
because if you were born in a country
where nineteen five four ninety six
percent of the people are Muslims there
are other things to discuss apart from
your identity